S
COMING UP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE WILL
CHECK BACK WITH YOU AND WE WILL
SEE YOU TOMORROW.
I'M LAURA INGRAHAM.
IS HIS THE INGRAHAM ANGLE FROM A
VERY BUSY WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
THE TRUTH EXTREMIST THREAT THAT
IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
THE END OF HIS SPEECH TODAY, I
DUNNO IF YOU SAW AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
BIDEN ENDED ON A NOTE THAT WAS
SWEET.
IT WAS HOPEFUL.
IT WAS UNIFYING.
BY DUE SIMPLY NOTHING BEYOND OUR
CAPACITY TO GET DONE IF WE DO IT
TOGETHER.
SO GOD BLESS YOU ALL AND PRAYED
THAT WE COME FIGURE OUT HOW TO
COME TO GET THE BETTER THAN WE
HAVE SO FAR BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE'S LIVES AND FUTURES
DEPEND UPON A.
>> Laura: IF YOU ACTUALLY
BELIEVE THAT, THEN YOU'RE JUST
AS NAÏVE AS ONE OF THOSE POOR
REJECTED GIRLS ON THE
BACHELORETTE.
>> NEVER STOPPED FIGHTING FOR
YOU.
>> RACHEL, I LOVE YOU.
>> YOU ARE GOING TO PUT ME IN
THIS CART RIGHT NOW.
>> IT COULD BE A MISTAKE.
>> IT IS.
I PROMISE YOU IT IS.
>> Laura: , THE TRUTH ABOUT THIS
ADMINISTRATION AT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IN GENERAL, IT IS NOT
FUNNY AT ALL.
IN FACT, IT IS DARK AND IT IS
SINISTER.
WHILE THEY HAVE BEEN BUSY
DESTROYING OUR PROSPERITY, OUR
BORDER, AND OUR SAFETY, THEY
HAVE ALSO BEEN WORKING OVERTIME
TO SELL A LED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> President Biden: DONALD
TRUMP AND A MAGA REPUBLICANS
THREATEN OUR REPUBLIC.
>> EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN SHOULD
STAND IN OPPOSITION AGAINST
THESE RADICAL MAGA REPUBLICAN
VIEWS.
>> THIS MAGA REPUBLICAN AGENDA
IS AN EFFORT TO DISRUPT OUR
DEMOCRACY.
>> IT IS A BIG REVEAL OF THE --
THE DANGER OF THE MODERN GOP.
>> NOW, THIS TOXIC MANTRA IS ALL
SILLY.
IT IS DRILLED IN THE NATIONAL
CONVERSATION DAY AFTER DAY.
IT PITS AMERICANS AGAINST
AMERICANS.
SOLELY BASED ON POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES.
NOW, HOW SICKENINGLY CYNICAL IS
THAT?
HOW TRANSPARENT?
THE ARGUMENT THAT CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICANS ARE THE MOST
DANGEROUS THREAT FACING US
TODAY, NOT THE CRIPPLING
RECESSION, NOT BUT NO COMING
FROM CHINA COULD NOT HIGH-ENERGY
BECAUSE COULD NOT'S DIRECTING
MURDER RATES.
BUT THOSE PEOPLE WHO SUPPORTED
TRUMP.
THEY ARE THE REAL MENACE.
THIS IS WHY BIDEN CAN'T COMMIT
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
>> President Biden: VEINS
BULGING.
THE VEINS BULGING AS THEY WERE
SCREAMING.
CARRYING TORCHES WITH SWASTIKAS.
DOWN IN VIRGINIA, CARRYING
SWASTIKAS AND TORCHES.
CHANTING THE SAME ANTI-SEMITIC
VIAL THAT WAS CHANTED IN GERMANY
IN THE EARLY '30s.
CHANTING THE SAME ANTI-SEMITIC
VIAL HEARD ACROSS EUROPE IN THE
'30s.
>> Laura: AND THEN THERE'S THE
INSTRUCTION THAT WAS NOT.
WHENEVER THE NEWS GETS BAD
POLITICALLY FOR BIDEN?
THE DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA TRY
TO SAVE THE PARTY BY GOING BACK
TO JAN 60.
>> WE WILL BE PRESENTING NEW
INFORMATION, NEW EVIDENCE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BECAUSE THE INVESTIGATION GOES
ON.
>> I PROMISE YOU IT WILL BE
INTERESTING FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
FOLLOWED IT.
UNTIL NOW AND HEY, IN A
DEMOCRACY THE PEOPLE HAVE THE
RIGHT TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT IS
GOING ON IN THEIR GOVERNMENT.
BUT I THINK IT WILL BE
POTENTIALLY MORE SWEEPING THAN
SOME OF THE OTHER HEARINGS, SO I
THINK IT WILL BE AS THE OTHERS
HEARING WORTH WATCHING.
>> Laura: OKAY.
YOU WANT TO KNOW THE NEW
INFORMATION?
TODAY THE DOUBT -- THE DOW
DROPPED FOR THAT SIX STRAIGHT
DAY.
AND INCREASE ME LOOKS BAD FOR
THE DEMOCRATS IN THE MIDTERMS.
NO CONCERN DAY'S WASHINGTON POST
ABC NEWS POLL SHOWS THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE GETTING KILLED ON
THE ISSUES THAT THE VOTERS CARE
MOST ABOUT.
THE ECONOMY AND CRIME.
AMONG REGISTERED VOTERS,
REPUBLICANS HAVE A 70-POINT
ADVANTAGE TRUST AND 18-POINT
ADVANTAGE ON INFLATION AND A
22-POINT ADVANTAGE ON HANDLING
CRIME.
IT IS NOT ENOUGH, THOUGH, THAT
THEY HAVE WHIPPED THEMSELVES THE
DEMOCRATS INTO A PANIC.
THEY ARE NOT WHIPPING THEIR
ACTIVISM.
THEIR ACTIVISTS INTO TRUE
VIOLENT EXTREMISM OVER CULTURAL
ISSUES LIKE ABORTION.
YEAH, I'M -- ON TOP OF THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO INSIST, RIGHT, THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP INCITED THE
CAPITAL RIGHT WITH HIS WORDS ON
JANUARY 6.
THEY NOW SOUND PRETTY CLOSE TO
THE INSIDE THEMSELVES.
>> WE ARE AT WORK WITH THESE
PEOPLE.
THESE FOLKS ARE EVIL.
THEY HAVE ALLOWED EVIL INTO
THEIR HOUSE WITH DONALD TRUMP.
>> THE MAGA MOVEMENT IS A
THREAT.
>> THIS IS AN ULTRABRIGHT ATTACK
ON WOMEN IN THIS COUNTRY.
THIS IS LITERALLY CALLED TO ARMS
IN OUR COUNTRY.
>> MAYBE NOW IT IS ALL ABOUT THE
VIOLENCE.
IT ALL IS ABOUT AN INSURRECTION.
IT ALL IS AND IS A CIVIL WAR.
>> Laura: NO, THEIR MESSAGE IS
BEING RECEIVED THAT INCLUDE.
STOP THE PRO-LIFE MOVEMENT BY
ANY MEANS NECESSARY, STOP THE
PARENTS WHO ARE OUTREACH ABOUT
TRANS-PROPAGANDA AT SCHOOLS BY
ANY MEANS NECESSARY.
AND VICE PRESIDENT SEEMS TO
THINK THAT PEOPLE WHO PRAY
OUTSIDE OF ABORTION CLINICS OR
WHO VOLUNTEERED AT A CRISIS
PREGNANCY CENTERS THAT THAT THEY
ARE EVIL INCARNATE.
>> SO-CALLED EXTREMISTS LEADERS
ARE PASSING LAWS TO CRIMINALIZE
THESE FOLKS.
PASSING LAWS TO PUNISH WOMEN.
I MET WITH MANY OF YOU IN MY
OFFICE AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND WE DISCUSSED THE INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES THAT YOU HAVE USED TO
DEFEND WOMEN'S REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM.
YOU ARE TAKING ON RIGHTLY.
THE CRISIS PREGNANCY CENTERS.
>> Laura: TAKING THEM ON?
IS THAT WHAT SHE SAID?
HOW TONE DEAF.
COMMON LOT GAVE THOSE
INFLAMMATORY REMARKS JUST A WEEK
AFTER YET ANOTHER CRISIS
PREGNANCY CENTER WAS VANDALIZED
WITH THREATENING MESSAGES.
IT WAS THE SECOND ATTACK ON THAT
SAME CENTER.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DO THAT THEIR
LAST VOLUNTEERS I THINK WHAT
THEY TRY TO DO WITH BRETT
KAVANAUGH AND AMY CONEY BARRETT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO INTIMIDATE
THEM AND SCARE THEM.
THEY HAVE ZERO RESPECT FOR THE
THE CORNER OR EVEN THE HOUSES OF
WORSHIP WHERE PEOPLE GO PLAY.
BECAUSE YESTERDAY, THESE SAME
TYPE OF ACTIVIST TOOK THEIR
VIOLENT RENTS TO NEW YORK
ST. PATRICK'S CATHEDRAL.
[CROWD CHANTING]
>> Laura: AND EVEN THE FBI IS
GETTING IN ON THE ACT.
CHARGING APRIL LEFT VOLUNTEER
AND A FATHER OF SEVEN WITH A
FEDERAL CRIME.
FOR WHAT?
A NOTHING SKIRMISH OUTSIDE AN
ABORTION CLINIC THAT WAS
ENTIRELY PROVOKED BY A LEFT-WING
ACTIVISTS.
THIS IS PERHAPS THE MOST
DESPICABLE ACTION TAKEN BY THE
FBI NEXT TO THE BIG DIFFERENT
DISPROPORTIONATE PROSECUTIONS OF
SOME OF THE JANUARY 6
DEPENDENTS.
AND IS EXPOSED TO POLITICAL
RESIGNATION OF OUR OWN DOJ AND
THE DESPERATION OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
NOW, THE ANGLE SAW THIS COMING
WITH THAT LEFT'S ROLL AND
ENCOURAGING AND EVEN REWARDING
THE DEPRAVED BEHAVIOR OF
DECEMBER OF 2020.
THE DEMOCRATS MESSAGE TO THEIR
PLACE AT THE TIME WAS KEEP IT
UP.
BUT HOLD ONTO THAT ENERGY
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO HARNESS
THAT EMOTION TOWARD A POLITICAL
VICTORY OVER TRUMP AND THAT
REPUBLICANS.
FOR DEMOCRATS THE DOZENS OF
LIVES LOST TO POLICE OFFICERS
UNFAIRLY TARGETED AND THE
PROPERTY LOSSES INCURRED BY
CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY, THAT
WAS ALL COLLATERAL DAMAGE FOR
THE GREATER GOOD.
IT WAS ALL A PARAGRAPH.
BUT NOW DEMOCRATS SAY THAT THAT
POWER IS THREATENED.
THE VOTERS DID NOT BARGAIN FOR
ANY OF WHAT THEY ARE SUFFERING
THROUGH RIGHT NOW.
AND RESIDENT THEIR POLICIES,
MAYBE TACKING TO THE MIDDLE OF
LITTLE BIT, LIBERALS AND THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY ARE GROWING MORE
VICIOUS BY THE MINUTE.
THEY ARE EVEN ATTACKING ONE OF
THEIR OWN.
ONE MINUTE DAY SET UP TO JOE
MANCHIN FOR THE CLIMATE CHANGE
DEAL, OR THE NEXT THAT THEY
TRASH HIM AND NOW THEY ARE DOING
THE SAME THING WITH CHRISTIAN
SEMINAR -- KYRSTEN CINEMA.
ACTUALLY ONCE IN WHILE TALKING
TO A REPUBLICAN.
>> THE ONLY PERSON WHO SEEMS TO
LIKE HER IS MITCH McCONNELL.
AT MITCH McCONNELL LECCE HER
BECAUSE SHE WORKS WITH HIM TO
OBSTRUCT THE DEMOCRATS.
SHE DOES NOT HELP THE DEMOCRATS.
WE DON'T NEED HER.
WE NEED A STRONG DEMOCRAT IN
ARIZONA LIKE MARK KELLY.
>> Laura: WHY DON'T YOU MOVE
THERE AND RUN?
AND WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE
AFTER LISTENING TO STUFF LIKE
THAT THAT THEY ACTUALLY CARE
ABOUT WOMEN?
NOT WOMEN WHO DARE QUESTION
THEIR TWISTED ORTHODOX?
THEY DON'T COUNT.
BUT THE -- ON THAT VIEW, I THINK
THEY ARE GOOD FOR ONE THING.
REMINDING US THAT TODAY'S
FEMINISTS ARE THE REAL MALE
CHAUVINISTS.
YEAH.
YOU ARE WITNESSING A
FULL-FLEDGED DEMOCRAT MELTDOWN
HAPPENING.
THEY DON'T ABOUT PREVENTING
VIOLENCE.
THEY NEVER HAVE.
DIDN'T CARE ABOUT SAVING
DEMOCRACY.
HE NEVER DID.
FOR PRESERVING RESPECT FOR OUR
GOVERNMENT INSTITUTIONS.
THEY ARE SO CONSUMED BY HATRED
FOR THE 74 MILLION AMERICANS WHO
VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP THAT THEY
ARE WILLING TO COMPROMISE ALL
THAT THEY ONCE BELIEVE IN
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO FREE
SPEECH IMPARTIAL JUSTICE IN
ORDER TO PUNISH THOSE SAME TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
WELL, THAT CAT GENTLEMEN, IS
WHAT I CALL DANGEROUS EXTREMISM.
BUT DEMOCRATS, THEY ARE THE ONES
WHO WILL BE PUNISHED LESS THAN
SIX WEEKS FR